[Music]
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom is in
theaters now and I've already published
a spoiler free review on my channel if
you don't want spoilers if you don't
want to know plot points if you don't
want to know my specific issues I had
with a few things towards the end and
some in the middle and some in the
beginning and really some all over the
place that's your warning this review is
going to contain spoilers also please do
stay tuned to the very end of this video
because I want to thank my sponsor
Dollar Shave Club for sponsoring this
video I'm gonna talk to you guys a
little bit about a special offer I have
running with him right now so fallen
Kingdom massively disappointed me I
wasn't a humongous fan of Jurassic world
that film also disappointed me but
nowhere near the same amount of
disappointment I'm feeling we are
immediately thrown into newsreel footage
of the volcano that's about to erupt on
Isla Nublar and a lot of animal rights
activists are chanting and picketing for
the rights of these animals that they
should be saved because they're alive
you know they're real living creatures
even though they were created by man in
a lab and according to Ian Malcolm
Nature selected them for extinction and
this new thing is a mistake that's what
Ian Malcolm has said throughout all of
his appearances in the Jurassic Park
films and once again at the beginning of
this movie he says that as well now
let's talk about something when it comes
to Jurassic Park fans what would you say
pretty much all of them agree on Ian
Malcolm's right when I watched Jurassic
Park I liked yep I agree with you this
is a mistake people are going to die in
the lost world he's like oh yeah that's
how it all happens at first but then
later there's running and screaming god
damn it you bastard and so this film
opens with Ian Malcolm saying once again
no this is nature correcting our mistake
this volcano that's going to destroy
these dinosaurs
that's a correction for what we did
wrong they should go extinct they don't
belong on our planet anymore and I'm
like yeah I agree they're dangerous and
countless innocents have already died
and this is a mistake Jurassic world the
actual park was an obvious mistake that
was one of my biggest issues with that
film is I just didn't buy that they
would actually make a park again
after all the problems that already
happened and so if all of the fandom
essentially is usually on the side of
Ian Malcolm and goes yeah this guy knows
what he's talking about
this film opens with him saying what we
know is right but then allows us forces
us really to follow two main characters
Claire and Owen who disagree with that
who think the dinosaurs should be saved
for the entire film and I'm just
thinking to myself I don't agree with
that and yet these are our main heroes
and to me that was a big mistake of the
screenplay because the film tries to set
up the dinosaurs as animals that need to
be cared for and protected and preserved
I am huge into animal rights I love
animals the fact that I don't agree with
this is because these things are
humongous predators that will go above
humans in the food chain if released and
our main characters they want to rescue
them and put them on a sanctuary
somewhere I get that they didn't have in
their minds what actually happens they
were thinking they were just gonna go
somewhere else which brings me to one of
my other big flaws with the film Isla
Sorna is an uninhabited island right
next to Nublar without a volcano just
move them there why not I mean that's
where they used to be according to Canon
the dinosaurs were moved from he's La
Sorna to Isla Nublar when Jurassic world
the park was finished so that place is
still over there just put him there
remember thank God for site B in the
lost world it's there just put them
there but no the writers want to make
Jurassic world 3 and I've said in my
review I said this film seems like a
placeholder almost like a movie that was
made just to get dinosaurs on the United
States in the in America because they
want to have a movie where the dinosaurs
are just running amok in America all
over the place not just in San Diego
like in the lost world and right here is
an interview with Colin Trevorrow on the
site up rocks and the question is asked
to him without getting into spoilers
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom seems to
end in a way that sets up something you
really wanted to do all along his
response that is accurate it is a movie
I've wanted to see my whole life and I
knew it would take too
movies to earn it and to get there so
yes he absolutely wanted to make
Jurassic world 3 he's already signed on
as director and that's exactly what this
film fall in Kingdom feels like it's
just like filler to get to something
else so I've already talked about how
much I could not stand some of the
characters in this film the the boy
who's there who has like neurotic panic
attacks and hates sounds and everything
for some reason he's on this island it's
just so I don't know why that choice was
made so we're just we're just gonna kind
of throw away for this video all of the
specific issues I had that were non
spoilery in my original review and just
focus on some of the spoilery issues
once they get these dinosaurs off the
island and at this mansion where this
guy Lockwood portrayed by James Cromwell
is close to death he has a young girl a
granddaughter who's running around and
she seems to really love dinosaurs and
loves her grandfather and this
businessman there is secretly going to
auction off all of the dinosaurs to like
cartoon people like there's one guy
who's like a twenty Millions
I'm like Jesus Christ pushing aside the
fact that there's a bunch of dinosaurs
and cages and people are auctioning them
off to warlords or people who just want
to hunt one of these dinosaurs in an
enclosure pushing the stupidity of that
aside let's focus on the price tags
because my friends and I after this
movie we went to a restaurant and we
were just sitting around talking about
the price tags the total cost from what
I remember for all of the dinosaurs
before the auction ends was like a
hundred and twenty million something or
other that's it
hell this movie cost a hundred and
seventy million the budget for this
movie costs more than buying actual
dinosaurs according to the screenplay so
I recall the little girl pressing the
negative three button and the elevator
to get down to the basement so that
means that I guess three floors down the
indoor Raptor is in a cage
and nobody but the few people working on
this thing noticed or heard it or maybe
felt the the foundation of their house
shake anything I mean if that thing was
a couple miles out here where I live in
Ohio I'd hear it
three floors below and you never notice
an Indo Raptor anyway so that things
down there and it of course you know it
breaks out because somebody does
something stupid and this amazing
creature awesome design it just runs
around some hallways for a while before
it dies I mean waste it's just a waste
of great potential now I mentioned in my
review there are specific visual
callbacks one of the most effective
scenes in the film and I didn't mention
it because this is kind of a spoiler is
once all of the dinosaurs are clearly
dying and everyone's on the boat and
they look back and you see the one
brachiosaur on the dock and it's like
obviously about to die it's being
overtaken by smoke and flames probably
my favorite part of the whole film it
rises up on its legs and does the iconic
pose from the first Jurassic Park and
I'm like well you just you just ruined
it and he kind of ruined it right there
it was so beautiful and then he had to
do a callback for some reason another
one was the t-rex roars at one point and
makes the exact same copy-and-paste pose
of the end of the first film with a sign
when dinosaurs ruled the earth it's
right there on the collection the 4k
collection the Indo Raptor running
towards the girl when she's in the
little elevator the dumbwaiter I should
say and she's trying to pull down the
thing just like in the kitchen scene
there's so many sequences that just feel
like unnecessary callback so it doing
the the handle in her in her window just
like the Raptors in Jurassic Park
there's just so many moments where
you're asking yourself is this its own
film what film is this one of my biggest
issues with the movie as as I said it
opens with us being told that these
dinosaurs are to be cared for protected
their animals they need to be preserved
and it wants to present them as animals
as living creatures that need protection
but it also wants them to be
monsters in a mansion that creep up on
little girls when they're in bed and
almost eat them if you're gonna present
a character like an Malcom in the
opening saying this is a mistake and
then we watch this mistake happen that's
understandable like in the first film
because everyone's there because it's
this amazing new thing but pretty much
everyone agrees with Malcolm Alan Grant
and Ellie Sattler what does Alan grant
say in Jurassic Park how can any of us
have the slightest idea of what to
expect and then John Hammond I can't
believe it the only one on my side is
the blood sucking lawyer that's one of
the reasons why we like the characters
in Jurassic Park so much because they
understand the dangers in wielding that
type of technology all of them except
for Hammond and the lawyer in Jurassic
world they're all Hammond and lawyers
they're all like yeah we need to save
the dinosaurs and it's a big thing and
they need to be protected and preserved
you're like actually nature already made
sure that we were safe from dinosaurs
and now you want to make sure that
there's more possibilities of danger the
film does have omen and Clare imprisoned
towards the end saying we're at fault
right now you know
I trained right Owen says I trained
raptors and showed people in the
military that they could be trained and
Clare feels at fault for controlling a
lot of Jurassic world but it's just that
one scene besides that they're still
thinking about freeing off titus
Torrence gratefully though towards the
end Bryce Dallas Howard she's about to
touch that button and release the
dinosaurs into the entire United States
population and she decides not to and I
went thank God okay smart choice and
that little girl just walks up and
presses the button we find out some
stuff about her she's a human clone she
was created by Lockwood because he
missed his real granddaughter who died
in a car crash and apparently that's why
he had a falling-out with Hammond so
she's the first real human clone but
what all is in her we don't know we get
a long lingering shot of her eyeball
I was expecting like some like her herd
of Lincoln for her I to suddenly turn
into a dinosaur I and if that happened I
would have just I would have got up and
left but I just can't stand the
stupidity of these moments it's a
screenplay filled with things like this
so as I said she presses the button and
releases the dinosaurs and everyone just
looks like oh shit well there's no going
back now and what does she say
I had to they're alive like me I mean
there's prisons filled with violent
murdering criminals that are also alive
like me that doesn't mean I'm gonna go
free them oh man this movie and honestly
I mean I went back and I watched the the
final trailer and so much of the film
like 95% of the story is present in
these trailers you see the dinosaurs in
the zoo with a lion which is like one of
the last moments of the film you hear
Ian Malcolm say welcome to Jurassic
world that's also one of the last
moments of the film I can't believe
Universal after the gigantic success of
Jurassic world and all the money they
made felt the need to market the film
like this and show everybody everything
gratefully I didn't see all that before
I saw the movie but this film vastly
disappointed me it is filled with so
many inaccuracies one last thing I
mentioned that it sort of messes with
the continuity of the other films by
inserting this this human clone into the
mix somehow Hammond was involved in this
or didn't want to be involved in there
it's just like why why is this even a
story why do we need a human clone girl
what did that add to this movie besides
the knowledge that it could be done
other Jurassic Park drafts of unmade
screenplays have explored human hybrids
and dinosaur hybrids and human hire and
all that stuff but there's a reason that
hasn't happened up until now it just
it's unnecessary it doesn't do anything
for this story this film if you really
want to make dinosaurs loose in the
United States instead of them going to
an
an auction at a mansion there could have
been something that made them break out
as soon as they got to land and then
they're in the United States I get that
you don't want you know the the
comparisons to the lost world with the
San Diego incidents but that entire
second act and much of the third act is
so slow and it's just filled with
unnecessary callbacks and and and like I
said my biggest issues is that the
characters don't agree with what Malcolm
is saying in the beginning and I do I'm
sure people will enjoy the film my
audience clapped a lot whenever the
t-rex did anything so those are my
spoiler filled thoughts on Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom I do hope that some
of you were able to find enjoyment in
the film because I just couldn't but
like I said the beginning of the video I
have a sponsor for this video and that
is Dollar Shave Club they're more than
just raisers you know Dollar Shave Club
is a grooming brand dedicated to helping
men take care of themselves so they can
look and feel their best without paying
an arm and a leg their five dollar daily
essentials starter kit is a great offer
for new members it comes with the
executive razor and a full set of
cartridges one wipe Charlies The
Wanderer calming body cleanser and dr.
Carver's easy shave butter in particular
felt very soft and super smooth all of
these products are extremely
high-quality in particular the six blade
executive razor its design feels sleek
and efficient it's six blades very high
quality and I want to thank them for
sponsoring this video please do go to
the link in the description below that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash Chris Stockman
and learn about their five-dollar daily
essentials starter kit so please do
visit dollarshaveclub.com slash Chris
Stockman because they're $5 starter kit
right now is giving away the executive
razor and three trial size versions of
their other products for a very low
price please do check that out and thank
you to them for sponsoring this video
guys thank you very much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon if you did see Jurassic world
fall in Kingdom I'm curious to know what
everyone thought of it thank you very
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]